m
dans le cadre de la semaine bleue
semaine nationale des retraités et des
personnes âgées de nombreuses actions
sont organisées dans toute la france
afin de mettre à l'honneur nos aînés
c'est à la salle des fêtes de la marque
les 14 clubs seniors de sainte marie se
sont donné rendez vous pour une journée
conviviale et festive
la semaine bleue ces privilégiés pour
les personnes âgées on va dire nationale
parce que ben ça touche quand même
tous les pays et donc nous on a pris
pour la semaine on a fait un programme
avec les présidents des clubs des
scénarios on n'a pas travaillé tout seul
il a travaillé les présidents et
aujourd'hui c'est un exposition vente a
donc battu de tout ce que les clubs et
les adhérents
on fait pendant toute l'année pour qu'il
puisse mettre en valeur le travail
aujourd'hui donc et avec aussi vendée de
repas des gâteaux compte qu'ils ont
confectionné eux-mêmes cette journée
exposition vente a permis aux différents
clubs de présenter le travail réalisé
tout au long de l'année une mise en
valeur de leurs ouvrages mais aussi un
moment de partage et des changes
moi j'ai exposé comment on fait là on a
un atelier de couture la prime et le
lundi après midi
moi j'ai fait des trucs de couture comme
les chapeaux sacs en fait ce qui qui
causent la couture alors d'été de relier
des manic tous à tout ce qui est dit
couture c'est moi qui fais le lundi
après midi à la maison des seniors et
l'âge exposés on a travaillé toute
l'année pour ça et donc on expose de ce
matin eh ben c'est à dire le bénin va
pouvoir aller dans la caisse de
l'association
donc c'est pas pour moi c'est pour
l'association autant que nous pouvons
levier toujours fait sans attendre les
dents
je te rends compte avec ma caméra
une journée très importante pour les
adhérents des différents clubs des
journées comme celles ci permettent en
effet d'oublier les petits tracas du
quotidien et de rompre l' isolement
c'est important parce que c'est la
journée des seniors des seniors et c'est
but de rencontrer parce que nous dans
notre club
on oublie le lâche plus le quotidien
très heureux on fait des petites choses
que ça peut ça peut être utile et ça
c'est utile ' ce point de vue santé 1
et là tout le monde s'y met on s'amuse
on échange ses amis moment convivial en
fin de compte on est bien là on ne
propose plus si on est malade on a peur
on pense plus la douleur
chaque année le conseil départemental
chef de file de la prise en charge des
seniors accompagne et soutient cette
grande fête de la citoyenneté solidaire